It started as an idea what if we made a
Deadpool movie there's only a few of us
back then and looking back we had no
idea how big it would become so innocent
and yet the momentum that had started
Yeah, that was not really what we had in mind
Nope, that didn't help things.
It was
more of a hell no to be honest and we
eventually stopped asking we have no
idea how that happened
but I promise you I'm looking into it.
Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my new Deadpool x-men video
over at Marvel you probably saw the
recent interviews that Rob Liefeld was
doing making all kinds of claims about
Marvel having no plan to do a new
Deadpool movie so we'll break it down
and explain what's going on behind the
scenes
why is he complaining so much about no
Deadpool over at Marvel when Ryan
Reynolds himself said that they're
working on the movie right now if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing a new
Amazon giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know
what you want them to do with Deadpool
inside the MCU so just going down the
list here starting with number 5 if you
missed the news Rob Liefeld creator of
the Deadpool character at Marvel Comics
did two separate interviews a couple
weeks ago making a whole lot of noise
about why he felt like Marvel Studios
and Kevin Feige are not doing Deadpool 3
during those he also talked about the
mainstream x-men characters too claiming
that they're inside a break this glass
in case of emergency box inside Marvel
Studios right now as in they would only
use big x-men characters if there was
some huge emergency with one of their
upcoming movies after he did those the
larger internet sort of picked those
interviews up and you started to see
headlines everywhere about Rob Liefeld
claiming that there is no Deadpool 3
movie so after that he tried to do a
follow-up interview walking back some of
his statements and clarifying what he
meant when he said that there's no new
Deadpool movie at Marvel so he's a comic
book creator who has a history of
getting into trouble online beefing with
people way back in the day before
Twitter existed going all the way back
to the 90s he used to get into a lot of
flame wars on forums because that's
where people did that kind of thing in
the comic book community now that kind
of stuff has just made its way onto
social media so hearing that he's making
a lot of noise complaining about what
Marvel is or is not doing with
characters that he helped create isn't a
brand new thing he's done this before
number four I've already done a couple
Deadpool three videos based on clips of
Ryan Reynolds talking about the movie
explaining what's going on with it
between those in the comments of the
Deadpool movie writers Rhett Reese and
Paul Wernick you get a pretty good idea
of what
going on with Deadpool in general over
Marvel right now not just the Deadpool
three movie but Deadpool has a character
inside the MCU late last year around the
holidays he went on talk shows promoting
his ugly-sweater charity and during
those he said we're working on Deadpool
3 right now over at Marvel pretty
general statement like yes things are
happening but I can't get into details
he met with Kevin Feige at their offices
a little before that cracking jokes
about auditioning to replace Robert
Downey jr. as Tony Stark unsuccessfully
then probably the best clip of him
explaining what's going on over Marvel
came from Fallon the other day where he
tries to explain how the Deadpool
character is going to fit into the MCU
in how the Deadpool 3 movie is going to
exist at Disney MCU or not in the MCU
his statement was something to the
effect that if Deadpool 3 winds up being
in the MCU it's gonna be amazing to be
able to play inside that sandbox with
all the pre-existing Marvel characters
the big Avengers characters in their
canon and if Deadpool 3 winds up not
being in the MCU and just being its own
thing off to the side then they can also
do pretty much whatever they want and
that would also be amazing the fact that
Ryan Reynolds put it that way made it
pretty clear that Marvel and Kevin Feige
right now just haven't hundred-percent
decided whether or not they want
Deadpool 3 to be a traditional MCU movie
like all the others mostly because it's
supposed to be rated R franchise and
Disney isn't known for releasing a ton
of rated R movies that's also why there
are no rated R movies on Disney Plus
right now right around avengers endgame
when they completed the buyout of Fox
the powers that be claimed that they
were gonna let Deadpool continue to be
rated R so I think a lot of us just
naturally assume that Deadpool 3 would
kind of be like the new mutants movie
when it came to MCU continuity and they
would just treat it like it's its own
separate thing the mythical new mutants
movie that hopefully we'll be able to
see some day is a Marvel horror movie
with x-men characters it's not rated R
it's pg-13 but because it was made at
Fox before the buyout Marvel is now
releasing the movie but technically it's
not being treated like a traditional MCU
movie it's just a movie with Marvel
branding and characters and there won't
be any big MCU post-credit scenes or
anything like that and if it makes a lot
of money there's always the potential
for those characters to return in other
Marvel movies or Disney Plus projects in
the future so
the reason why people flipped a little
when Rob Liefeld came out and said there
were no plans at Marvel for Deadpool
movies is mostly because he has been
involved at some level with the
development of the previous Deadpool
movies at Fox so he's not completely on
the outside on all this big movie stuff
he actually does have people that he
knows and talks to at Marvel about
what's going on with movie stuff
he's the creator of the character so
when Fox greenlit the first Deadpool
movie they brought him in is a creative
adviser Marvel doesn't do that as much
nowadays but it does like comic book
creators do big cameos Stan Lee style
best recent example is jim Starlin the
person who created theaters had a huge
cameo scene in avengers endgame as that
greek counselor at the beginning of the
movie if you haven't watched that first
deadpool movie in a while Rob Liefeld
had a cameo scene as one of the bar
patrons it's a blinkin you'll miss it
kind of cameo but he is in there in real
life though as a comic book creator he
doesn't have a great relationship with
Marvel he is a history of disputes with
them over a comic book stuff over
business and financial matters now that
Kevin Feige has hundred-percent taking
control of Marvel Comics that kind of
puts him on the outs with Marvel Studios
tangentially usually in the past if
someone seems like they're making too
much noise are too hot to handle Marvel
will just ignore them or freeze them out
or stop returning their phone calls so a
lot of people just felt like maybe he's
just upset that Marvel doesn't seem like
they plan to involve him in Deadpool 3
on any kind of creative level number two
the core of his statements about there
not being a Deadpool movie in Marvel
mostly revolve around the idea that it's
only because Marvel hasn't officially
put Deadpool 3 on the schedule and he's
trying to say that Marvel won't take
Deadpool 3 seriously until they make it
official and put on the schedule like
remember the big Marvel phase 4 schedule
revealed at Comic Con they revealed 11
projects in two years including Disney
Plus series and then a little while
after that they published part of their
Marvel phase 5 movies scheduled through
2022 so this isn't all the Marvel phase
5 movies it just through 2022 some of
these mystery phase 5 movies have been
revealed since then but obviously they
haven't officially put deadpool 3 on
this schedule yet Rob Liefeld claims he
knows what Marvel's full five-year movie
plan is and he said he
didn't see Deadpool on and in somehow
that means they're not gonna do Deadpool
3 but when you really think about it
that's kind of a ridiculous statement
the reality I think is that a lot of you
have guests based on Ryan Reynolds
comments the reason why Deadpool isn't
already officially on the schedule is
because one Bryan Reynolds just booked a
ton of other movie projects he's making
a movie with a rock right now it got
shut down because of the virus so
already pretty much everything has been
delayed for at least a half a year then
once Kevin Feige starts making noise
officially about Deadpool 3 usually
takes him about three years to get a
movie out because it gives me about a
year to do the script and then two years
to actually film and complete the movie
in post-production and right now Marvel
just doesn't want to announce every
single movie for the next five years
because if anything in the last couple
of months have shown you is that plans
for movies can change on a dime think
about what the virus did to the phase 4
schedule not just at Marvel but pretty
much every other studio every single
Marvel phase four movie just got delayed
big time even a couple years ago they
had to completely take guardians of the
galaxy three off the schedule so number
one it just doesn't make sense for
Marvel to give dates for every single
movie including Deadpool 3 if it's not
ready to release it in the next two
years one of the main reasons why you
usually hear Rob Liefeld making a lot of
noise about Deadpool is just because
he's the most popular character he's
ever created and he still earns a lot of
money from the licensing deals and the
toy sales the comic book sales
merchandise all that stuff so the more
money the Deadpool character makes just
in general from all the different
revenue streams the more money he winds
up making at the end of the day so of
course he would make a lot of noise
about Deadpool recently Netflix also
bought the rights to his extreme
Universe characters like the Youngblood
characters and they also just greenlit a
profit movie for one of his other
characters Marc Guggenheim the creator
of arrow is also going to be writing
that movie so at the end of the day
Liefeld is kind of a hype man for
himself so anytime there's stuff that's
announced projects that he's working on
you can usually count on him to make a
lot of noise about stuff and while that
happens he usually also gets asked a lot
of Deadpool questions so it wouldn't
take his comments about Deadpool and not
happening at Marvel too seriously I
would take more cues from Ryan Reynolds
and the other people at Marvel they say
they're working on it so I would take
them at their word
they are working on it right now just
because so much stuff has been delayed I
would say earliest we see Deadpool 3 now
is probably 2023 so just mark your
calendars and if they have any more
updates or official news about Deadpool
3 of course I'll do a new video about it
but leave all your big questions and
your reactions in the comments below
everyone click here for that full
Deadpool 3 Ryan Reynolds clip and click
here for my brand new Marvel Ghost Rider
project breakdown thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!